There are four billion hours of travel delays in the United States every year, contributing to pollution,
Waste fossil fuels cost us all the money. An estimated $ 87.2 million dollars! No
Male traffic is just annoying! But there is a solution to your traffic problems?
It is often due to construction, accident, or bottlenecks created by ladders on traffic tunnels.
But do you ever feel like congestion seems to appear for no reason? You do not imagine
that! In the 2008 experience, the drivers were instructed to drive along the ring road after
The car is in front of them while trying to maintain a constant speed. Where participants,
They began to fluctuate in speed. These fluctuations increased, eventually causing
The cars stopped completely which broke free flow and led to traffic jams without any addition
Factors. Researchers compared traffic jams to molecules in liquid and solids.
Moving cars are like free particles that flow into liquid, but can undergo a "transition"
To solidify the capsule. Once the particle / motor reaches critical density, inertia occurs.
One of the main causes of choking occurs is our inability to maintain a constant speed.
When the traffic interruption occurs, the most accelerated to catch the car forward, resulting
When braking in the end, it imposes on the drivers behind to slow down, causing congestion to grow.
When you're in traffic jam, you're part of the problem. Studies show that 80-90% of the
Drivers think they are better than average driver, which is ... impossible. In addition to,
As humans selectively our attention, we tend to forget that other drivers are people
Also - kind of like its online comment, we can humiliate other drivers in ways we did not
face to face. This leads to tremors on the road - yet very closely or constantly changing
Lanes - which contributes directly to the congestion that creates traffic jams.
Fortunately, a good driver, you can make a difference! Pay attention to the car of the future
And behind you to keep a reserve of space around you. That way, if the driver in front of you
Brake, your room to slow down and will not pass the braking tension along the chain
traffic movement. Drive slower. Set your car to cruise control or try driving at a constant speed.
In Belgium and the Netherlands, there is a technique carried out in times of high volume
Known as "driving block" where a series of fixed speed propulsion vehicles to help
Others keep up. The police have also used this strategy for 15 years, and leadership in the proper
Speed ​​in groups to maintain traffic flow.
Of course, the advent of self-driving independent cars sees cars that are able to
Communication and communication with each other, vehicle to vehicle, is expected to reduce
Great traffic jams. In addition, researchers use biologically inspired
Algorithms to reduce travel time. In one study, researchers apply a model based on
Ant travel behavior as a means of directing traffic. Changes in infrastructure work too. Recently
Los Angeles became the first city to synchronize every street light, causing automatic lights
Adjustments based on flow, resulting in reduced travel time by 14%.
Traffic aside, another solution is to take public transport when possible. MIT study
From Boston traffic was found that if 1% of existing drivers took transit, would ease everyone
Is reduced by 18%.
Of course, companies like Toyota - who have supported this episode - are finding new ways to meet
Motor challenges, and the development of future technologies to connect drivers and vehicles with
Road infrastructure. Toyota Launches New Corolla Im Hatchback With Toyota Safety
Feeling techniques such as pre-collision systems, high automatic beams, Lane departure alarm
- all of which will be standard and launch all over Canada in September. They also have
A goal to produce zero emissions cars by 2050 which we really support!
Therefore, special thanks to Toyota for supporting our channels and being a leader in science
And space technology!
Subscribe to get more science weekly videos!